because the judge didn't like this the
judge ordered her to give 100 of the
laundry Wings a hundred crazy
[Music]
you know I thought this lady was kind of
clever it didn't work out for her but
there was this woman who filed for
divorce
and hid lottery winnings from her
husband and is now forced to hand over
the jackpot oh I heard there was a there
was a documentary out about people who
win the lottery and so many people just
get completely [__] over by their
family yeah it's a lottery person and
you're like oh my God I had no idea it
was that it's almost every time yeah
yeah there's a high almost every right
suicide rate there's like it's the
someone kidnapped her granddaughter and
then they go broke on top of all yeah ah
that sucks I was just doing a podcast
episode about this on my Army Nikki's
podcast but then I'll tell you right we
were talking about how like all the
times that people have won the lottery
and it's never good news in fact I had
to search out good news just to like
give a couple stories where it's like
this person actually found someone and
they invested it but otherwise it's
[__] yeah because most people who are
playing the lottery are already not
financially responsible yeah it's like a
high rate of uh correlative that's true
I didn't think about it yeah I don't
understand why people have to do
disclose your name what's the whole
what's the hole you have to pay more to
not have it disclosed really well some
states you don't have to oh that's
that's where it is yeah that's awesome
here I think you have to you have to
give a little bit back to the lottery
I'll give if I won the lottery
I would give as much back as I need
let's see but see the difference there
is are will you play the lottery
probably not because I'm going to is
that a challenge right I'll [__] play
the lottery dude don't tell him he can't
do something don't tell me I can't do it
I'll [__] do it you know my dad
always forget about it by tomorrow my
dad always said you can't win if you
don't play
um and then I was like hey Dad you
should buy crypto and he's like nah
because I'm not trying to win and he was
right he was wrong that's true man all
right so this check we're gonna call it
Rossi and a number of her work friends
went in on a California Lottery
Syndicate and their numbers came in just
11 days before her divorce papers were
filed back in 96. she won 1.3 million
dollars we decided that she wouldn't
tell her husband Thomas about it because
again this was just 11 days before yeah
yeah it's only years later that the guy
finds out when he gets a letter from the
company that pays out a lump sum to
lottery winners it was addressed to
Denise of a Rossi and said that the
company helped hundreds of lottery
winners like you around the country
receive a lump sum payment for the
present value of their future annual
Lottery payments damn they totally just
ratted around you can either choose to
get them in installments which gives you
more money over time or you take a lump
sum which is way less of it which is the
smarter way and you can YOLO it though
you said lump sum is smarter no because
you're you're not going to be able to
overcome your own urges it's better to
have it come in little by little
obviously but then how do you still lump
Summit how do you YOLO it if you don't
get a lump subject but that's the whole
point the people that YOLO would get
[__] because we already don't have
discipline it's so hard but you know the
fear about taking installments have you
heard of it what so like let's say you
choose the installments thing what stops
them from sending someone to just
[__] kill you
Jesus Oh the lottery company yeah dude
Ryan's kind of dark because then they
don't it's kind of not right do you know
you know the installments thing can't be
passed on to another person right really
yeah if you do have discipline uh though
the lump sump is better just by in taxes
if you look at it that way and then over
time and inflation you lose value for
how much money you're getting so like by
the 10th year or whatever it's not worth
the same amount that you had before dude
I think I'm only getting two million a
year I think Bart's wrong about the the
lumps the human psychology wise I don't
think most people are strong enough yeah
but well that's why there's a lot of
your curves I mean you have the
statistics already that tell you the
truth yeah and it's right it is true so
what if like I don't know if this works
but like let's say your lottery winners
technically you're a Millionaire right
on paper
then can you not buy that amount in life
insurance where the benefactor is your
significant other and so if they do kill
you if they kill you then they they
that's have the money it seems like to
Ryan's point you know that are you
buying lottery tickets
well I think that's that's a that's an
idea that a lottery winner probably
doesn't have that's what I'm saying
people who actually play don't already
have these like do so intellectual
thoughts about Finance they do so little
investment around themselves after this
happens and it's like it's YOLO people
that play and the people that DCA don't
play Anderson exactly exactly they're
such trash people that the people around
them often try to kill them I'm not yeah
that was the biggest thing that I
uncovered doing all the research for
this thing I had no idea people around
them are are hella Mercury dude yeah
they're gonna kill you crazy everyone
everyone comes out for handouts yeah
yeah you can't just give me a million
dollars
is the UFC fighters one-liners but he
was on Joe Rogan and so he came from
like a super
like poor Hood in Houston and he said
he's like you know multi-millionaire has
Lambos and stuff like that and his Joe
Rogan's like do you ever help out your
family and he goes [__] no and he's like
why he goes one time I bought my cousin
a car and he sold it to buy drugs he's
like [__] that I ain't ever helping him
I'm like oh [__] I feel like crazy
stories yeah and the people would always
as soon as he made his first money
everyone said help me help me help me
help me please please please and then
everyone that he has helped has all
backfired exactly yeah when it doesn't
it doesn't actually help anybody really
yeah right because everyone needs to
help themselves I mean that's that's why
I'm glad there's statistics behind this
because you it's not just like a oh
speculating on no people's lives get
[__] up from Lotto yeah but the people
that would should read the statistics
don't yeah and they played Lotto yeah so
what if we just played the lotto more we
need to DCA the lotto buy a ticket every
day then we have we're way more likely
to win 300 times likely there's people
that win it twice yeah isn't that crazy
and then they lose it positions who hack
the [__] City yeah there's there's
math people we gotta find some
mathematicians there's a movie right now
out about a couple that
um I think it's the Indiana or Illinois
Lottery but he's the the he was a
mathematician and he figured out like a
flaw yeah him and his wife go around
just like making a lot of that lottery
cash and help their town and [__] and
whatever so in this situation the court
heard that uh Denise Rossi got the
actual check sent to her mom's house
withholding the information from her
husband and I of course the divorce
court which is a huge thing you can do
oops she said that she wanted to get out
of the relationship for years but her
husband Thomas argued that he'd been
blindsided and was left confused by what
happened uh quote she wanted me to move
out of the house very fast it wasn't
like her to act this way because you
know imagine winning the lottery and
suddenly be like oh yeah we gotta hurry
up this divorce okay I'll get out yeah
yeah so he secures it and just happened
for a long time
he secures an injunction bless you takes
her to court uh where it's ruled that
she violate violated laws around the
disclosure of assets and funds before
the divorce acting in fraud or malice
and uh because the judge didn't like
this the judge ordered her to give 100
of the laundry Wings a hundred crazy
I'll cut on her side what the [__] I'm
kind of on his side I'm kind of on her
side dude what the 100 that's wild the
lawyer sick the lawyer her lawyer even
said that she'd have had a chance of
keeping some of it if she'd only told
them about it before quote I could have
argued successfully that it was her
separate property or we could have
argued and we would have reached some
adjustments but the judge got mad it
gave it all to him this is like how you
punish siblings that don't share food or
something yeah I didn't think this could
happen in actual litigation but it's
clear ill intense so it makes sense like
how the judge was like well on the base
of morality right it's ill intense she
wanted to keep it away so you don't
deserve any of it dude if you've tried
to [__] the state over they they're
gonna [__] you so hard and there's
probably an assumption that the divorce
was just maybe like a falling out of the
relationship versus like malice on one
side like you know what I mean but she
was already gonna divorce him though
right who knows thing yeah but still the
idea it could be a no-fault state where
it just doesn't matter whatever it is
you just divorce dude that judge is
that's when she commits murder if I was
her I would commit murder I think that
was my that's my next one if I was her
I'd kill that guy at the same time
though I think that dude that dude's a
[__] yeah oh wait there's you had a
million dollars like me and Geo got
divorced I might take everything I'm
rebuilding I don't give a [__] yeah kind
of right I'm starting from scratch and I
will [__] [__] I'll [__] on you I
will [__] on you I'll [__] kill you
every [__] thing but there's a law in
the divorce court where you're supposed
to disclose all of your assets so that
you yeah so what I'm saying what I'm
saying is and she's imagined Geo
specifically
code yeah and then the street code he's
saying that before it even gets to that
I think I think legally it should have
been 50 50 whatever but if you find out
after the fact it's like [__] it dude
what street code is I'm gonna be
homeless you take everything I live in a
tent I'll build it all back [__] [__]
you [__] yeah that's really good
because honestly when you get divorced
you'll be able to work more anyway you
have way more exactly yeah
like you're gonna spend quality time you
just spend all your time working
and stuff he's in a tent she's in a
mansion
sometimes you ever do you ever just
fantasize being by yourself sometimes
and just like just be myself this sounds
like a slippery I just like the idea of
him being at actual legal hearing going
oh [__] [__] on you
I'm gonna destroy you I'm gonna make so
much money now
some say the biggest haters are your
biggest fans it works out here take
everything and then she's like this is
just your phone
you're like yeah this is everything you
know the pictures on here how many
members I got on here how am I gonna
feel myself working out yeah
say it is pretty good that's pretty wild
but that is crazy too that you're
willing to relinquish 100 I do think
though like before you're a [__] if you
can't manage
thing right people think
people think it's all the [__] time a
thousand bucks a month what makes you
think you're gonna manage Millions yeah
that's true like if you can't even
manage small batches of cash like you're
gonna [__] it all I think I think so
much money you can't run out a million
is so much money you can't run out yeah
in their brains yeah yeah yeah I already
spend that [__] so fast the hardest part
is you lose that [__] so fast yes sir
yes sir
like the odds that a Lotto winner will
have a healthy Social Circle is asking
too much too oh yeah that's too much of
an ass especially scratchers if it's
scratchers it's over for you oh dude and
if that's the most interesting thing
that has ever happened in your life all
your new friends you make that's what
you're open with yeah right right and
then so now you how do you know people
are your real friends you know right
laughs
[Music]